hey folks my name is jake host and
producer of gamespot after dark
gamespot's official video game podcast
this snippet comes from this week's
episode featuring charity streamer
optimistic gamer
who specializes in mythology if you
enjoyed this clip and you want to listen
to the full episode just search for
gamespot after dark on the podcast
service of your choice
and if you really really enjoyed it make
sure to like and subscribe because that
really helps us out
anyway without further ado let's roll
the clip
last question here is from kevin from
west hartford hey after dark crew
after the heavily rumored switch update
this year what could nintendo's next
move possibly be for their next console
i feel like after the switch they can't
take a step back and make an exclusively
handheld or tv console
this is this is the big question of the
week i think we've there's been plenty
of rumors
we've talked about it briefly but i kind
of wanted to dig into this and see what
people's thoughts are on what nintendo
can do next and remember
we have a show called console crew and
they cover this stuff regularly but we
haven't really
dived into it on the podcast yet so i
figured that would be a good time
any thoughts i i i am they're definitely
going to go
like a wii u route with a switch 2 but
probably a lot better because unlike the
wii which sort of just like had this
you know huge success and then just
immediately died because
iphones came out and nobody cared
anymore like i think the switch
i think they'd have a lot more success
with just like a proper switch too so i
know that's kind of boring but like i
think
i think they're just gonna iterate on
the switch
really yeah i think so too i don't think
we'll get a new console i think it'll
more be a refresh and i know people have
said this before but i imagine
a switch pro something that can run
higher resolutions better frame rates a
better screen would be nice like
oled they need to redo the joy cons
the joy cons oh please dear lord
i have giant andre the giant hands and
those joy-cons are not
they're not good for me the thumbsticks
don't feel good like the pro controller
feels so good it's like it's crazy how
good the pro controller feels and how
bad the joy cons feel and it's like this
is you made these at the same time like
how did this
happen but it's not even that it's like
joy-con drift which they've been
dealing with for a while now and it's
something that
i i've never actually ran into that
issue but i think it's because i didn't
play handheld all that much and i
usually played with the
pro controller but but a lot of people
still get hit with that even on the
switch light too apparently
right wasn't that also an issue on that
i think it's much rarer yeah
yeah it is my partner had got a switch
light and
there's there's a starting to get that
and i've noticed that i i
had it for my joy cons um where i just
come back and link would have like
shimmied his way into another corner
somewhere else because of that
yeah yeah i mean i think overall i think
the big thing though for them is just
getting into that 4k
space because i mean 4k is becoming more
popular i think
just having a console that can
that can look good on 4k tvs is going to
be pretty important
but i mean at the end of the day though
like
like nintendo knows that they're best at
just making
really good games that that that appeal
to a lot of different people
and i think like i don't know nintendo's
weird because i'm not sitting here like
when's the next nintendo console coming
out like many people are i just
want more games because i yeah i love
nintendo games
i also feel like they're at a space
where
i think some people probably in their
head are like oh i want like all the
the big third-party games to also be on
nintendo like an assassin's creed but at
least for me
it's like i don't know like we're at a
point now with indie games where it's
it's not about like the hardware it's
just about like the types of games and
the types of experiences they make that
really like
you can play on on any hardware now you
can play on a phone you can play on a
switch so like i don't
outside of of improving maybe like the
big
first party nintendo games i feel like
nintendo
sits very comfortably as like this
indie platform that can kind of support
these smaller tier
games because i think we're slowly
getting away
from every game needing to look like
you know this insane like naughty dog
level
masterpiece like i think those people
know like you get a playstation if you
want that like i don't think people
that's what people are looking for with
a switch any thoughts kelly
the main um room for improvement is in
performance right
and the stuff that you guys mentioned
but i also
like i i struggle with this question
because i don't think there's any way i
could predict what nintendo will do
like like nintendo doesn't really
like as a company has not really cared
about what is
trendy or what is the highest tech
like or what the competition's doing
yeah
yeah so it's hard to say like what their
next move would be because like
i think nintendo's whole thing is like
surprising you
with something that you didn't expect so
i i mean i think the switch is totally
ideal i love
handheld gaming i use my switch light
basically
exclusively i don't really uh play on
the tv match
part of that is the way my living space
is set up right now i don't really play
a lot of games on
on a tv right now but um yeah like i
just i don't know how to answer this
because i just feel like the next thing
they'll do i'll be like
oh i didn't even know i wanted that
because i feel like
when the switch was announced i feel
like everybody was like a little bit
like nintendo's like what's
skeptical one two switch interesting
concept
um and like the
the thing that happens with nintendo
hardware is typically there will be like
some
core uh concept around it and then the
use cases will evolve throughout the
console's lifetime so you saw that with
like 3d on the 3ds being like
the main like the the forward-facing
aspect of it but of course there was so
much else that
you know you like the portability you
like street pass you like you know the
library is fantastic so
it i'm interested to see what like the
core
idea would be and how that would evolve
like i
i feel like i'm not good enough or
knowledgeable enough at any of this to
like come up with
what that could possibly be because i've
i've been consistently uh surprised
so yeah it's just a hard it's hard
question to answer
like i know like what i would want i'm
like bluetooth for my headphones
like uh or you know like maybe i should
try something more ergonomic because
i'm going to give myself carpal tunnel
um
from the amount that i play uh the
switch
within you know not with the pro
controller so
yeah i don't know i'm like thinking you
know if there's like integrations
well i i think that's that's a super
fair
prediction though because to your point
i mean
i remember the gamecube being somewhat
of a surprise and then
with microsoft and sony with the
playstation 3
and xbox 360 nintendo was like no we're
not really gonna
do that hd thing we're just gonna do our
own thing and it ended up doing really
well
same with the wii u they kind of didn't
try to chase that and same goes again
for the switch so i i mean
i think that's one of the defining
things about nintendo right is that it's
just tough to predict
what they're going to do uh except maybe
re-release some
some games that people want for full
price i was gonna say if there's one
thing that i've
i always really really want them to do
it and i don't know i don't know if they
ever will because it just seems like
they don't care about it but like i
would love for them to really go hard
and just like in in celebrating their
back catalog
and like you know everyone's like hey
are you gonna put
you know and 64 games on the switch
you're gonna put gamecube like
they had this golden period with the wii
where it was like
so amazing to have access to all these
retro games that
they just abandoned after
that system and like you can't even like
play those games like
like they shut that service down and and
there's that part of me that's like i
just want
nintendo to like finally like
provide a a service for their back
catalog
that is like compelling and isn't
just like this insane drip feed
um but i don't know if that'll ever
happen
because i've been wanting i was gonna
say i
they could make money like they could
they literally like
formulate it out of air like alchemy
because it's there's so much there
i i've like callie kind of like touched
on
on it oh i've i've always thought of
nintendo as
it's its own island like it exists
outside it's amazing because it's like
nintendo defined
the the quote-unquote console wars or
whatever that's
that are now more or less dead and
now we have and for for so long nintendo
just does
what it wants to do and it knows how to
do it
and you you couldn't have said it better
yourself like i could have said it
better myself when you said like
they make things that i didn't know i
wanted they're really good at doing that
um and having this having the switch be
iterative
would sort of play on what they did with
the fact that they dominated the
handheld market for so long
with you know the ds into the into the
the 2ds and the
3ds and how just how much they just
unless it's a phone it's there is no
competition and
i don't see like it's almost like why
would you change like why would you try
to
tamper with what they've done with the
switch in terms of its accessibility
the fun aspects of it i didn't think i
was going to want to make a bunch of
cardboard toys for my video game console
but i do
yeah it's wild yeah and you said
something there
like the the to to make it iterative i
think that
like that's what i would expect right
that's kind of why i said like i don't
know
what to predict because i feel like i
expect that and maybe they won't do that
but i would expect
like rather than completely revamping
the console like you know the switch is
like such a
like it's just struck gold lightning in
a bottle sort of
of a piece of hardware like why not just
work to make it
more powerful longer battery life more
accessible uh you know it would be cool
if people were able to use custom
controllers and stuff like that
um so that's what i would expect like
that's
that's what i know that i want right now
but then i feel like nintendo's going to
be like just kidding this one uploads
games to your mind
i'm just gonna be like wow vr
i'll tell you one thing the next switch
will not be called the switch you
oh as long as it's also not called the
new switch
which oh or that yeah which they might
do
considering nintendo 3ds new nintendo
3ds new super mario brothers
i guess snap is game freak but but
it works still it works until
you know new super mario bros turns 20
years old and then it's like yeah
that doesn't work anymore
[Music]
[Music]
you